so
from the highest possible topic of
consciousness
to the to the lowest level
uh topic of david goggins uh
i don't know if it's low low level he's
high performance
high performance right but like like
there's no
i don't think david has has any time for
philosophy let's just put it this way
well it's i mean i think we can tack it
to what we were just saying in
a in a meaningful way which is whatever
goes on
in that abstraction part of the brain
he's figured you know he's figured out
how to
dig down in whatever the limbic friction
yeah
he's figured out how to grab a hold of
that
scruff it and send it in the direction
that he's decided it needs to go
and what's wild is that he's what we're
talking about is him doing that to
himself
right he's it's like he's scruffing
himself and directing himself in a
particular direction
and sending himself down that trajectory
and he
what's beautiful is that he acknowledges
that that process
is not pretty it doesn't feel good
it's kind of horrible at every level but
he's created this
rewarding element to it and i think
that's what's so it it's so admirable
and it's what so many people crave which
is
regulation of the self at that level
and he practices i mean there's a ritual
to it
there's uh every single day like no
exceptions
there's a practice aspect to the
suffering
that he goes through it's principled
suffering and principled suffering
and i mean i just i mean i admire all
aspects of it including
him and his girlfriend's wife i'm not
sure she'll probably know that i don't
know beyonce
wonderful we're not asking him no no
we've only community
we've only i've only communicated with
her um by a text about some stuff
um i was asking david but yeah they
they clearly have formed a powerful team
yeah
um and it's a beautiful thing to to see
people working in that kind of synergy
it's inspiring to me same as with elon
that a guy like david goggins can find
love that that you find
a thing that works which gives me hope
that like whatever
whatever flavor of crazy i am you can
always find
another thing that works with that but i
i
i've had the some maybe let's
trade goggin stories uh you're from a
neuroscience perspective me from a
uh self-inflicted pain perspective i
somehow found myself in communication
with david about some challenges
that i was undergoing um
one of which is we were communicating
every single day email phone
about the particular 30-day challenge
that i did that stretched for a longer
of uh push-ups and pull-ups you made a
call out on social media yeah social
media
actually i think that was the point i i
knew of you before but that's where i
started
tracking some of what you were doing
with these physical challenges and i
um the hell is wrong with that guy well
no i think i actually i don't
often comment on people's stuff but i
think i commented something like uh
neuroplasticity loves a non-negotiable
rule i know i said a non-negotiable
contract
because at the point where yeah
neuroplasticity
really loves a non-negotiable contract
because
you know and i've said this before so
forgive me but you know the brain is
doing analysis of duration path and
outcome and that's
a lot of work for the brain and the more
that it can pass off
duration path and outcome to just reflex
the more
energy in it and it can allocate to
other things so if you decide
there's no negotiation about how many
push-ups how far i'm going to run how
many days how many pull-ups etc
you actually have more energy for
push-ups running and pull-ups
when you say neuroplasticity you mean
like the brain once the decision is made
it'll start
rewiring stuff to to make sure that this
we can actually make this happen
that's right i mean so much of what we
do is reflexive at the level of just
core circuitry breathing heart rate all
that that boring stuff digestion
but then there's a lot of reflexes stuff
like how you drink out of a
mug of coffee that's reflexive too but
that you had to learn
at some point in your life earlier when
you were very little analyzing duration
path and outcome and that involved a lot
of top-down processing with the
prefrontal cortex
but through plasticity mechanisms you
now do it so when you take on a
challenge
provided that you understand the core
mechanics of how to you know run
push-ups and pull-ups and whatever else
you decided to do
once you set the number and the duration
and all that
then you all you have to do is just go
but people get caught in that tide pool
of just
well do i really have to do it how do i
not do that what if i get injured
without you know can i sneak at this so
that you know
and that's work and
to some extent i i look i i not david
goggins obviously
um nor nor do i claim to understand his
process
uh partially you know um but
maybe a little bit which is that it's
clear that by making the decision
there's more resources to devote to the
effort of the actual execution
well that's a really like what you're
saying was not a lesson that was obvious
to me and it's still not obvious it's
something i really work at
which is there is always an option to
quit
and i mean that's something i really
struggle with
i mean i've quit some things in my life
it's like stupid stuff
and uh one lesson i've learned
is if you quit once
it opens the door that
like it's really valuable to trick your
brain
into thinking that you're you're gonna
have to die
before you quit like it's actually
really convenient so actually what
you're saying is very profound
but you shouldn't intellectualize it
like it took me
time to develop like out
psychologically in ways that i think i
it would be another conversation because
i'm not sure how to put it into words
but it's
really tough on me to uh to do
certain parts of that challenge which is
a huge you know there's a huge output
the the number that exceed i was i
thought it would be the number would be
hard but it's not
it's the entirety of it
especially in the early days was just
spending i'm
kind of embarrassed to say how many
hours this took so i i didn't say
publicly how many hours because
people i knew people would be like
don't you aren't you supposed to do
other stuff well it's uh
how are you doing again i don't want to
speculate too much but occasionally
david has said this publicly where
people will be like don't you sleep or
something yeah
and his process used to just be that he
would just block delete
you know like gone but it's it's
actually um
it's it's a super interesting topic and
because self-control and directing our
actions and the role of emotion
and quitting these are these are vital
to the human experience and they're
vital to
performing well at anything and
obviously at a super high level
being able to understand this about the
self is crucial
um so i have a friend
who was also in the teams his name is
pat dossett he did nine years in the
seal teams
um and in a similar way
there's there's a lore about him among
team guys
um because of a kind of funny challenge
he gave himself
which was so he and i swim together
although he swims further up front than
i do
um and he's very patient um but
you know he was on a he was assigned
when he was in the teams to a position
that
gave him a little more time behind a
desk than he wanted and it's not as much
time
out in deployments although he did
deployments um so he didn't know what to
do at that time
but he thought about it and he asked
himself what what does he hate the most
and it turns out the thing that he hated
doing the most was bear crawls you know
walking on your hands and knees
so he decided to bear crawl for a mile
for time so he was bear crawling a mile
a day
right and i thought that was an
interesting example they gave because
you know like why pick the thing you
hate the most
and i think it maps right back to limbic
friction it's the thing that creates the
most limbic friction
and so if you can overcome that then
there's carry over
and i think the notion of carryover has
been talked about psychologically and
kind of in the self-help space like oh
if you run a marathon it's going to help
you in other areas of life
but will it really will it well i think
it depends on whether or not there's a
lot of limbic friction because if there
is
what you're exercising is not a circuit
for bear crawls
or a circuit for pull-ups what you're
doing is you're exercising a circuit for
top-down control
and that circuit was not designed to be
for bear crawls or pull-ups or
coding or waking up in the middle of the
night to do something hard
that circuit was designed to override
limbic friction
and so neural circuits were designed to
generalize
right the stress response to an incoming
threat that's a physical threat was
designed to feel the same way
and be the same response internally as
the threat to an impending exam or
divorce or marriage or whatever it is
that's stressing
somebody out and so neural circuits are
not designed to be for one particular
action or purpose so if you can
as you did if you can train up top down
control
under conditions of the highest limbic
friction that when the desire to quit is
at its
utmost either because of fatigue or
hyper arousal being too stressed or too
tired
you're you're learning how to engage a
circuit and that circuit is forever with
you
and if you don't engage it you it sits
there but it's atrophied
it's not it's like a plant that doesn't
get any water and a lot of this has been
discussed in self-help and growth
mindset and all these kinds of ideas
that circle the internet and social
media
but when you start to think about how
they map to neural circuits i think
there's some utility because what it
means is that
the limbic friction that you'll
experience in i don't know
maybe some future relationship to
something or someone
it will it's a category of neural
processing that should immediately click
into place it's just like the limbic
friction you experienced
trying to engage in the god knows how
many
uh push-ups pull-ups and and running uh
you know runs you were doing 25
000 was counting so folks if if
lex does this again more comments more
likes
no well there's a problem with you
getting more followers as you're going
to
get more actually i should say that's
the benefit i i don't know maybe it's
not politically
correct for me to ask but like there is
this uh stereotype about russians being
you know like likely correct not like
like
like being really um you know durable
and and you know i i
started going to that russian banya that
way back uh before covid
and um they could tolerate a lot of heat
you know and they would sit very stoic
you know no one was going oh it's hot in
here they're just kind of like ease into
it um
so maybe there's something there who
knows it might be something there but it
could be also just personal i just have
some
i found myself everyone's different but
i've found myself to be able to do
something unpleasant for very long
periods of time
like i'm able to shut off the mind and
i don't think that's been fully tested
and i monkey mind or the super computer
uh well it's interesting i mean um which
mind does
which mind tells you to quit exactly
limbic limbic friction tells you well
olympic friction is the source of that
but
who are you talking with exactly so
there's a um
we can put something very concrete to
that so there's a paper publishing cell
you know super top tier journal uh two
years ago
um looking at effort and this was in a
visual environment of trying to swim
forward toward a target and a reward
and it was a really cool experiment
because they manipulated uh virtually
the visual environment so um the same
amount of effort was being expended
every time but sometimes
the perception was you're making forward
progress and sometimes the perception
was you're making no progress
because stuff wasn't drifting by meant
no progress so you could be swimming and
swimming and you're not making progress
and it turns out that with each bout of
effort
there's a epinephrine and norepinephrine
is being released in the brain stem
and glia these what traditionally we're
thought of as support cells for the
neurons but they do a lot of things
actively too
are measuring the amount of epinephrine
and norepinephrine in that circuit
and when it exceeds a certain threshold
the gliac and inhibitory signals that
shut down
top down control they literally it's the
quit you
stop there's no no more it's you quit
enduring
it can be rescued endurance can be
rescued with dopamine
uh be so that's where the subjective
part really comes into play so you quit
because
um you've learned how to turn that off
or you've
learned how to some people will reward
the pain process so much
that friction becomes the reward and i
you know when you talk about people like
goggins and other
people i know from special operations
and people have gone through
cancer treatments three times you hear
about you know
just when you hear about people the
victor frankel stories i mean you hear
about
nelson mandela you hear about these
stories i'm sure the same process is
involved again this speaks to the
generalizability of these processes as
opposed to a neural circuit for a
particular action or cognitive function
so i think um you have to learn to
subjectively self-reward in a way that
replenishes you
uh goggins talks about eating souls
it's a very dramatic example in his mind
apparently
that's a form of reward but it's not
just a form of reward where
you're it's like uh you're picking up a
trophy or something it's
it's actually it gives the energy it's a
reward that gives more neural energy and
i'm defining that as more dopamine to
suppress the noradrenaline and
adrenaline
circuits in the brainstorm so ultimately
maps to that yeah he creates
enemies he's always fighting enemies i
never
i think i have enemies but there are
usually just versions of me
inside my head so i've i thought about
through that 30-day challenge
i tried to come up with like fake
enemies
it wasn't working the only enemy i
came up with is david well now you gotta
be off you certainly have a a
former formidable adversary in this one
i don't care
i'm uh david i'm willing to die on this
one come on let's go there uh but
well let's hope you you both uh uh both
survive this
um well my problem is the physical
there's uh so everything we've been
talking about
in the mind there's a physical aspect
that's just practically difficult
which is like i can't like you know when
you injure yourself at a certain point
like you just can't
function or you're doing more damage
yeah you're talking about it
taking yourself out of running for yeah
um
for the rest of your life potentially or
like you know or
for years so you know i'd love to avoid
that right there's just like stupid
physical stuff that you just want to
avoid
you want to keep it purely in the mental
and if it's
purely in the mental that's when the
race is interesting but
yeah the the problem with these physical
challenges as as david has experienced i
mean
it has a toll on your body i tend to
think of the mind is limitless and the
body is kind of unfortunately
quite limited well i think the key is to
dynamically control your output
and that can be done by reducing effort
which
doesn't work for throughout but also by
restoring through these subjective
reward processes
and and we don't want to go down the
rabbit hole of why this all works but
these are
ancient pathways that were designed to
bring resources to an animal or to a
person through foraging
for hunting or mates or water or all
these things and
they work so well because they're down
in those uh
uh circuits where we know the zeros and
ones and
that's great because it can be
subjective at the level of oh i reach
this one
milestone this one horizon this one
three meter target
but if you don't reward it you it's just
effort if you do self-reward it it's
effort
minus one in terms of the adrenaline
output
you